[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen im süden
israels heute geht
und ich zeige euch mal die vier
verschiedenen sorten die ich heute zu
bereiten werde nämlich waldfrucht
joghurt
[Musik]
burg irgendwas zitrone
kokos mango und
erdwärme und
dieses eis ist wirklich sehr sehr
schnell hergestellt ihr braucht nur
wenige zutaten dafür ein paar früchtchen
ein paar andere zutaten und es geht echt
super league muss jetzt alle hin
tschuldigung
dann mach es halt allein
ich zeige euch mal die zutaten fürs
erste eis
zuerst zeige ich euch jetzt das ebt beim
ins eis für sap bereits nehmt ihr 400
gramm frische erdbeeren ein paar
minzblättern etwas vanille extrakt und
zitronensaft ja da brauche ich
eigentlich gar nicht so viel dazu sagen
ihr braucht einfach nur einen mixer oder
pürierstab die erdbeeren sind jetzt
gerade in der abwehr zeit wirklich
richtig schön frisch sie sind vor allem
recht süß das heißt ihr braucht hier
auch keinen zucker dazugeben also nehme
ich jetzt einfach die erdbeeren und
kurier sie mit ein paar minzblättern
vanille extrakt und zitronensaft
[Musik]
vanille und erdbeer passen halt gut zu
sehen
deckel drauf
und mixen
riecht schon perfekt und jetzt nehmt ihr
euch am besten entweder silikon förmchen
also pop single förmchen entweder eis
förmchen oder was sie auch machen könnt
ihr könnt auch kleine zwischen kleinen
schnaps bücher nehmen und da das ganze
einfüllen und holzstäbchen oder leere
joghurtbecher soll man früher eben auch
fruchtzwerge eis gemacht hat also so
könnt ihr wirklich besser variieren oder
wenn ihr auch habe eiswürfel förmchen
und dann können wir so kleine clubs
machen also kleine eiswürfel zum essen
am besten lässt sich jetzt einfüllen
wenn ihr erst mal die stäbchen reinmacht
und dann schön einfüllen
[Musik]
und das frage ich jetzt ein am liebsten
nämlich dafür einfach so ein alu blech
weil es eben ganz gut ins gesicht
verpasst ansonsten einfach so ins
gefrierfach packen und einfach nur
einfrieren bist du schön gefroren ist
wenn ihr hier so einen kleinen rest noch
habt einfach mit wasser auffüllen oder
zb sprudelt dazu geben dann habt ihr
noch ein schönes apple getränk dann geht
es direkt weiter mit der zweiten sollte
jetzt gibt es das cremige und leckere
kokos mango es mittlerweile gibt es ja
echt gute reife mangos und die erkennt
sie daran dass sie so ein bisschen schön
weich ist und die reife mango könnt ihr
auch ganz einfach stehlen ohne viel
aufwand ihr nehmt einfach und hiermit
innern ist ein ganz großer flacher kern
er schneidet quasi mit einem großen
messer rechts und links davon entlang
[Musik]
und hier könnt ihr einfach oben den
kerner schneiden
[Musik]
und dann nehmt ihr euch
ein großes glas soll so ein bisschen
dünnwandig sein und dann könnt ihr
nämlich einfach hier die mango ansetzen
und dann kann sie so absehen und dann
landet die schale außen und das
fruchtfleisch innen
[Musik]
und auch diese kleinen stücke könnte und
so ganz einfach sagt zack zack
da kann man nämlich ken taylor
und dann wiegt ihr davon einfach
ungefähr 400 gramm ab also gebe ich
jetzt für euch im block an wenn die man
bisher weniger hat ist halt so dann ist
das so und
dann einfach mit zitronensaft und
vanille extrakt pürieren
[Musik]
ich finde das ganze jetzt in der dose
flasche ein so kann ich es gleich etwas
besser funktionieren
wir können natürlich auch hergehen und
sagen kokosmilch und reist sirup gibt
die auch gleich mit rein aber so habt
ihr gleich den effekt dass es zweifel ob
ich habe ein zweifarbiges ich nehme 30
group ihr könnt aber auch in anderen
sirup nehmen oder einfach die butter
zucker
[Musik]
und da nehme ich jetzt die eisfilm sind
diese in so ein bisschen aus wie das
triste eis und jetzt kann ich es hier
nämlich so ein bisschen im wechsel
einfach nur einfüllen also bisschen
mango bis in kokons
damit es richtig schön
[Musik]
dann gern so ein bisschen klopfen
dann verteilt sich schön glatt
[Musik]
zeit für nummer drei und das wird jetzt
ein schöner cocktail
aus gurke irgendwann zitrone zauber ich
das dritte eis für euch für diesen
cocktail braucht ihr 400 gramm gurken 20
gramm ingwer 60 gramm reis sirup und 60
gramm zitronensaft
kommt einfach auch wieder alles in max
und ich sag's euch dieses eis ist glaube
ich so von allen vier sorten so dass
erfrischendes eis denn es besteht ja zum
großteil aus gurke und für mich ich
kenne so nein ich habe schon gemacht und
für mich ist es so erfrischend lecker
auch nicht so mega süß ich kann davon
glaube ich einfach so die komplette
portion essen ja einfach alles hier in
mixa rein und auch hier wieder wie
gesagt entweder reist sirup oder einfach
eine andere süße verwenden
etwa wenn ihr mutig seit gern 20 kommen
wenn ich ein bisserl weniger
[Musik]
ich glaube das ist so das party eis
schlechthin denn dieses gefrorene eis
könnte später dann zum beispiel einfach
in so ein general
dann hab da meist sonnig
[Musik]
überschauen klopfen dann ist die luft
weg die stäbchen schön gerade rein und
immer schauen dass nichts überläuft dann
hat man später ein schönes perfektes
sauberes
rocker guckt ganz skeptisch bestehen und
sich dabei dem max probieren ein short
kanzlerin versprochen
auch sellerie apfel eis das
nicht so schaaf nicht so süß aber wenn
ihr möchtet könnt ihr auch gerne mehr
süße dazu geben aber ich finde so
blicken wir uns nochmal richtig
erfrischend schon super
nummer drei jetzt kommt die 4
[Musik]
und sorte nummer vier ist das waldfrucht
joghurteis fußball spruch reiße verwende
ich 200 gramm etwa 250 gramm himbeeren
150 gramm blaubeeren etwas limettensaft
tonka passte und 100 gramm reis sirup
und für die joghurt masse habe ich hier
300 gramm joghurt nämlich ein
naturjoghurt 100 gramm reis sirup und
etwas manuell extrakt auch hier startet
jetzt direkt wieder im mixer da kommen
nämlich alle 35 fruchtsorten rein und
ihr könnt natürlich jetzt entscheiden
was ihr zu hause habt ihr könnt auch
ganz andere obstsorten verwenden aber
ich finde seine waldfrucht mischung das
passt schon ganz gut mit lenka passte
[Musik]
tanker passte für den geschmack
und natürlich reist
[Musik]
dann kann ich jetzt hier den joghurt mit
dem reis die rub verrühren also mit der
anderen hälfte
und bisschen vanille dazu
dann habt ihr da einfach auch noch mal
eine schöne süßes
[Musik]
und dann finde ich das jetzt hier wieder
in die dosen flaschen ein
[Musik]
so empfehle ich jetzt hier auch die
waldfrucht masse ein dann riechen nein
wieso
dann die joghurt masse und wenn ihr
wollt könnt ihr das ein bisschen noch
marmorieren
des komischen dürfte es aber nicht
wundern es geht halt einfach ein
beispiel es riecht wie ein baby vor aber
halt das ist
aber ein bisschen auch nach penaten
creme oder schweiß
riecht komisch ja aber was schmeckt
bestimmten zweck bestimmt richtig gut da
gucke ich mach hier so ein bisschen
wahlspruch bisschen yoga
so
habt ihr sonst rain man zu hause den
seiten stimmten hinter ihren mann steht
eine frau die die augen verdreht oder
getrost hinter jedem lustigen man steht
die frau die die augen verdreht als gast
des
kindes nicht retten die frau immer so
auch gesagt gar nicht
okay auf jeden fall ich gebe dir den
garten und
ich finde ich immer nur stehen folge
[Gelächter]
das ist so schön
[Musik]
alle vier eissorten erledigt jetzt
werden sie eingefroren und dann was ich
später weint ihm probieren war doch gar
nicht so schwer oder
[Musik]
nachdem das eis gefroren ist könnt ihr
es ganz vorsichtig einzeln aus silikon
förmchen herauslösen und dann direkt
probieren ich hole jetzt mal mein eis
probier komitee zusammen und dann dürft
ihr verkosten
ok probierte mal gucken wir mal wie es
schmeckt so schnelles gesundes manchmal
um gesundes leckeres eis
am stiel
[Musik]
jetzt fragen was euer favorit ist aber
ihr habt ja alle nur eine sorte
[Musik]
ja das war es eigentlich also das war
mein eis video ihr könnt ja gerne
schreiben welche dafür sorten euch am
meisten anspricht welche ihr problem
wollte am besten alle vier würde ich
sagen und dann haben wir das ist so den
sommer über hier im tiefkühlfach die
menge die wir haben reicht uns für einen
tag
viskose team aber so viel zu hause auch
grad zubereiten mit kindern richtig wie
sie probiert gern aus und wenn ihr
weitere ice rezepte wollt findet ihr sie
schon auf meinem kanal da können wir
auch gerne vorbeischauen oder euch auch
gern noch welche wünschen schreibt im
rhein bis dann
ist als 23
[Applaus]
[Musik]